nobody that's a leader
would not do what i did and i know
there's a risk there's a danger but
that's okay
[Music]
i just left walter reed medical center
and i learned so much about a virus
don't
be afraid of it you're going to beat it
we have the best
medical equipment oh be afraid of it
feel great like
better than i have in a long time
i didn't feel so good don't
be afraid of it you're gonna beat it we
have to pour on a virus
don't be afraid of it and now i'm better
and maybe i'm immune i don't know be
afraid of it don't
let it dominate don't let it take over
your life be afraid of it
don't let that happen you're the
greatest country in the world afraid of
it
as your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger do it but i had to do it
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentary
let's go to the phones at six one seven
eight three
zero forty seven fifty um let's see
let's first
go to uh oh you know who's on the phone
donald trump is holding on and last time
it was off the rails
and that that intrigues me i'm in an off
the rails sort of mood
[Music]
and when this happens is this like
parents is it
siblings cousins what like generation
relative to you is i've said that if
ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps i'd
be dating her
hold on let's slow down because there's
a lot there let's really think it
through
she's got the best body yeah she made a
lot of money as a model a tremendous
amount and then she went cold turkey and
gave it all up because she had to go to
college because i wanted
to go to college she goes to the best
college she goes to work
let's take a step back let's address a
couple different things
it ultimately the answer is really in
you
in the sense of what do you want your
relationship to look like
with these family members right because
i i could give you advice that would
smooth things over but to make you feel
like you're depressed
[Music]
well yeah i mean just work on being a
normal person my friend i'm gonna let
you go
david you're born a certain way and
doesn't really change that much
okay i don't believe any of you that's
all the time i have for calls today
sorry i wasn't able to get to everybody
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
convalescent flows with strong
antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection
[Music]
convalescence
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million to fund the mayo
clinic study that tested the
efficacy of convalescence
the virus
[Music]
convalescent
all right everybody welcome wow what a
uh
a three-song introduction unbelievable
from dj
joseph woodward there we are once again
finding ourselves
uh on the precipice of a captain covid
super spreader event coming to a city
near you
tonight in des moines iowa where we have
any number of people awaiting the
arrival of president donald trump
by my best estimates he departed the
white house only 10 minutes late
and thus i'm hoping that this event
starts no more than ten minutes late
anticipation building i am going to talk
about what we will be seeing
tomorrow night from the standpoint of
these two town halls that are now
replacing
uh the debate which has been canceled so
i'm going to talk about that i'm going
to
read messages from from you guys via
super chat and twitch subscriptions i
have a few
memetic elements for you uh i have also
some interesting video
of donald trump from earlier today of
really struggling to speak and so we're
going to talk about
all of that i appreciate all of the
support from people moondog has just
subscribed with prime with the message i
looked into subscribing very strongly
it looks like you came out on the right
side of that investigation which i
appreciate
let's look at some super chats as are
as as they come in
chakaseki wants to know whether i think
lieutenant lung spurs will set up a
kissing booth at the rally
to sate his roid-fueled sexual lust
for the men and the beautiful women i
believe we will see that
i believe we will see that uh the flying
scotsman
says by suspending the census early
thereby misrepresenting the population
and particularly minorities
is trump deliberately gerrymandering
probably
probably yeah hound dog asks whether i
plan on making an electoral map
prediction soon yeah i mean you know
honestly i
i i can put it together right now very
quickly and very powerfully
sort of like for the most part where i
am and you'll very quickly see
let me clear that let me clear the map i
don't even need
any hints i can just clear it hold on
let me uh hold it let me see if i can
get this right
um there we go so i mean listen alaska
is going red and hawaii is going blue
oh my god there's ads everywhere hawaii
is going blue
there we go we'll close that out um the
three west coast states are going blue
montana red idaho red utah red
new mexico blue colorado blue wyoming's
red the dakotas are red
nebra actually nebraska is more of a
complicated
uh situation where i think we will have
um i think nebraska will ultimately look
like this
i think nebraska two is going blue
a kansas and oklahoma red now i know
there's a lot of talk about texas i
think texas is ultimately going to go
red
maine i think will go powerfully blue i
think new hampshire's done this year i
know sometimes new hampshire is a swing
massachusetts rhode island connecticut
new jersey delaware
maryland dc strongly strongly blue
south carolina is going red alabama
mississippi louisiana arkansas missouri
illinois will be blue indiana red
kentucky will be red west virginia will
be red virginia blue tennessee red
so now is where it gets oh i'm sorry new
york new york is of course
going blue so listen this is ultimately
what it comes down to now i know that
there's a lot of talk about
georgia maybe going blue i think we have
to assume it goes red but try to make it
blue
okay um i do think
that um uh we we oh minnesota is going
blue trump's talking about winning
minnesota i certainly don't see it
so then you've got this stuff okay now
i'm putting nevada on the blue side
um and i think iowa will ultimately go
red
and i do think arizona is going to go
blue so what do we ultimately have here
we ultimately have these key states
and then you've got florida and ohio now
here's the interesting thing
um let's imagine that biden gets north
carolina
and trump gets ohio we've now got these
three key states and florida
now i said earlier in the week if um
if biden doesn't win any of these
if it goes red red red it comes down to
florida
if biden gets florida biden wins if
trump gets florida trump wins
uh and and there you have it okay now
going back and and
removing florida for a second if biden
gets
any two of these three or even
potentially just
pennsylvania trump can get wisconsin
michigan and florida
and biden still wins i think the most
dangerous scenario is one where it comes
down to florida
if it's you need if it's if it's
not decided with only florida
outstanding i think it's a bad night for
joe biden
but of course these elections are not
completely uh
separate so in in my mind like if
biden gets florida i think he of course
gets wisconsin and michigan and then
it's a blowout
if biden doesn't get these or maybe gets
only one but michigan goes red and
pennsylvania goes red
then florida uh going to trump
oh that that's actually still a biden
scenario that's interesting
i this is you know assuming i'm right
about nevada and arizona
um but listen what the hell do i know
you know what i mean
anyway i did it okay people asked me to
do it and i did it
but i will have something a little more
definitive for you guys at some point
over the next very short period of time
all right
let's see what else we've got um joe
marcus says alpha tim poole has very
powerfully challenged lefties on twitter
to go on a show to debate
would you consider it you know um i
saw from his discussions with hassan
[ __ ] and sam cedar that he wants it in
person it's like i'm not getting on a
plane to do tim poole's show if he wants
me to skype in i would think about it
but um yeah i only tangentially heard
about that it is interesting
daniel krieger says i like your escaped
convict look yeah i was actually i was
um
i was with the sheriff's department
picking up trash on the side of the road
earlier i just kept my uniform on
just for kicks amy gray says david if
trump wins and you move to denmark will
you still cover american politics i will
i will i will be in copenhagen um
i will be at fisk bar tremendous
restaurant let me see if it still exists
fisk bar copenhagen do i remember that
correctly
yeah imagine going to a restaurant
ladies and gentlemen
this is the place to go in copenhagen
right here this is an extraordinary
place in fact when i went
you could it's hard to tell because of
the text but my girlfriend and i sat
right here
at this table and it was just lovely
lovely lovely place what did i have i
didn't have the crispy cod skins
although that sounds really good
uh these are not dollars by the way this
is uh
danish danish kroner um i think i just
had fish and chips to be perfectly frank
if i'm per if i'm completely frank i had
fish and chips which was
which was really really great okay what
else do we have going on here
lily says do you think trump will dance
tonight i hope so oh
okay let me get to that i have video
earlier donald trump did not sound good
listen to this
uh this does not sound super healthy
simply put it's a choice between a
socialist nightmare and the american
dream
that does not sound good let's listen to
that once more simply put it's a choice
between
a socialist nightmare and the american
dream
there it is and one this administration
sold out american workers like never
before
and they sold them to donors special
interests and
globalists and if you take a look we
have probably plenty of them watching
right now
i understand where you're coming from
but didn't work out too well with me
we succeeded by reversing all right and
then i guess one more
instead of corrupting horrendous trade
deals written by lobbyists and special
interests
again some of you i negotiated
pro-american trade deals
based on the principles of fairness and
reciprocity
very important i ended the
nafta nightmare and signed the brand new
u.s mexico canada agreement into law
i've taken the toughest ever action
against china's chronic
rate abuses oh my god all right all
right i can't i don't think i can do two
more
let's see if there's any uh maybe pick
one more
um okay that seems like it's really it
uh i might cover this tomorrow
okay yeah that's um
yeah we'll leave it at that okay so
anyway so that was earlier today
and very very ugly situation there
halloween it's halloween there
let me say a few thank yous boris
chacuani
i hope i'm pronouncing that correctly is
new member number one today
graham meacham is new member number two
and hold on
margaret gaten is new member number
three
beautiful i love that uh grab yourself a
membership and i will sing your praises
even if i don't uh know who you are i
was i will still sing your praises
i very much appreciate some of the
messages coming in over on twitch
muchel says love the content david keep
it up
the freak has subscribed for eight
months on twitch
and says hey hey david p i have been
subbed for eight months with a four
month
streak keep it real my friend appreciate
that
um ketilia steele has subscribed and
wants me to say david say
yip yip i'm a pretty little fox oh my
god i hope that doesn't make it into
some kind of racist
meme aaron nance has subscribed for 13
months with the message love the plasma
did you see trump gave
baron kovid yes i did i did i did see
that and it is uh completely and
absolutely toxic
okay let's do people want a meme should
we look at a meme anybody want a meme or
should do are we not doing fresh
fresh memes today um
no memes people don't want memes oh my
god that's rare
usually people are desperate for memes
people want memes okay
all right here's one i was sent all
right i think you're going to like this
this is one of our viewers when they
want to listen to lo-fi
plasma and a woman doesn't want them to
a woman in their life i don't know who
this woman is all right let's take a
look at this
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
convalescence
[Music]
oh that drink spilling on that that got
his attention when the drink spilled on
the window that was just too much
so anyway there it is i actually have no
idea where that's from i assume it was
adapted from from something else
but very clever very very clever i love
it
you can get fresh memes on a daily basis
on our subreddit
at davidpakman.com slash reddit
we're also on tick tock you guys want to
know something completely insane
i don't know what the hell is happening
on tick tock
my little sister understands it i don't
know i somehow have 16 000 followers on
tick tock
i don't know what on earth is going on
don't even understand it
i i don't i don't know what's going on
but tick tock
very very strongly looking i guess tick
tock is still legal
it has not been outlawed yet which
definitely comes as a shock
to a lot of people all right let me talk
about tomorrow night
so originally tomorrow night was going
to be
debate number two it was going to be
joseph r biden jr versus
donald mango trump and um after trump
caught the virus the commission on
presidential debate said
let's do it virtual via zoom or
something like it
uh so then donald trump said hell no i'm
not doing that they could just mute me
essentially is what he said he said
something like they can silence you or
something like that
so then the decision was made okay well
biden will just get 90 minutes he'll get
a 90 minute town hall i guess it was
going to be a
town hall format so um
then the presidential debate was just
canceled and
joe biden is getting his own town hall
and then there was a rumor that trump
was going to do a town hall now you
would imagine that sensibly they would
not do these town halls at the same time
they would do one and then the other
even on different networks
msnbc has scheduled a trump town hall
for the exact same time as the biden
town hall now i believe the biden one is
two hours eight to ten eastern
and the trump one is only one hour eight
to nine interesting trump claims to be
the stamina guy
somehow biden's doing two hours trump's
only doing one
that's a side story but i think it's
ridiculous to
do them at the same time in the end i
don't think it'll really matter
electorally
but we i i am going to be covering them
live
on youtube because i am more confident
that the live stream
won't get you understand you all get it
right
i think it's not gonna be on uh on
youtube
twitch i don't know i don't know what
could happen because these are now not
open source uh debates these are now
network um town halls so we will see we
will see what happens from the
standpoint of twitch
and i am not so sure about facebook
either but so i think
my point is the point i'm trying to make
is i will at minimum
at minimum see you on youtube tomorrow
night
probably a half hour before the town
halls start
now one idea tell me what you think
about this if
indeed the trump town hall is an hour
i'll do the trump town hall eight to
nine and then go to go to the biden
town hall nine to ten how does that seem
fair what do people think about that
let's see what people in the chat think
about that i mean it's the
it's an idea it's an idea
some people seem to like that so then
it's just an hour of each
makes sense
yeah it seems you know i guess that's
the benefit of
biden going twice as long as uh as trump
and you know to be perfectly frank
going first to trump might build the
audience
more quickly and then we carry it all
over to biden so that's the idea
and i will see everybody uh tomorrow on
that irene
economou is new member number
four today at joinpackman.com
taking advantage of the um
a discount code let's see oh grandmaster
benjamin feingold
is watching on twitch yeah we are going
to do a very
strong lesson soon and i think that
with benjamin feingold coaching me my
chest rating
could conceivably go from 10 30 to 10
40. i think that he could actually get
me up 10 points in a relatively short
period of time so we're going to be
announcing that at some point
relatively soon which i think is going
to be a great great thing people will
enjoy it
fun will be had by all let's see what
other super chats we have coming in they
they are coming in
darren dalton says deepak be a trump lie
tracker for the last debate
okay ritalin stunted growth says can you
put a link to that dj i can't find him
and that music was dank
yeah uh let's see people want if people
want
soundcloud uh joe woodward
soundcloud let's see
i mean honestly if you just google joe
woodward soundcloud it's the first thing
that comes up and all of the hits are
there
so i won't um i won't go too too into
that
um yeah a user named edith i'm gonna be
careful with this one because i think
it's trying to goad me into saying
something a user named edith says
hi that sweater looks nice on you it's a
t-shirt actually this yeah
it's it's just a t-shirt my girlfriends
and i think you wear an extra small
because you have a tiny
frail frame and chimp long arms can you
confirm
you know what is unbelievable i wear a
small not extra small
the chimp long arms thing some of you
have heard my very strong
sales stories from when i
worked at circuit city in high school i
was actually in the top 200
sales people nationally at circuit city
while in high school if you can believe
it i had to get my parents permission to
go to the sales excellence
dinner in orlando florida god i'm glad
i'm not in that field anymore
anyway one of my good friends and
manager at the time
roman he immediately identified that my
arms are relatively long for my body
and he while i was doing sales i was
pitching service plans to people
he would be walking around in the
background kind of like
putting his arms down past his kneecaps
in the and if so
while i'm trying to he was trying to
disturb my numbers which was crazy
because it would count against his bonus
but in any case
he identified that my arms are
relatively long
and he would try to describe distract my
warranty sales
by walking in the background pretending
to have arms so long that they would
almost reach the floor okay
um harper says did you see the meme i
made you on
insta i did not i i don't if so the
place to send me things is not
instagram i have if i look right now
on instagram um you know dozens of
messages and i just it's not a good
place to send me anything
so uh send memes using the website
contact form
at davidpakman.com
um i'm scared about patriotic education
yeah i would i would be scared as well
jacob says am i worried about a trump
judicial coup with amy coney barrett on
supreme court given the hearings
absolutely i'm i'm deathly afraid of
that very very scary stuff
danny thompson says suburban women will
you please like me
asks trump not only no but no way no
is what this suburban white boomer
non-college-educated evangelical woman
christian woman says in reply wow
very powerful very very powerful it
looks like the
uh trump acolytes are starting to stir
and get a little bit wound up which
suggests to me donald trump may be close
to landing
my estimate was that trump left the
white house about 10 minutes later than
scheduled so
hopefully this will be not more than a
10-minute delay judging from donald
trump's voice
earlier i don't know if we're going to
get a very long speech from trump if you
missed it
uh this was this was donald trump
earlier stray deals written by lobbyists
and special interests
again some of you i negotiated
pro-american trade deals
based on the principles of fairness and
reciprocity
very important i ended the nafta
nightmare
and signed the brand new u.s mexico
canada agreement into law
the pinnacle of health my friends truly
truly the pinnacle of health so
we'll keep an eye on that and listen if
trump's voice is like that and it starts
raining
trump will be out of here out of here
because he uh cannot
uh afford uh for the rain to ruin his
hair
other super chats coming in nicholas
silva
says do you think you can strongly look
into doing a segment
on aliens on gnars i like that or is
that a silent g
just nars tommy moon says you have a
girlfriend
yes straightforward super chat michael
is back and missed us all
jake says david concerning the wildfires
in california are most of them on
federal lands wouldn't the feds be
responsible ps plasma i don't know the
jurisdictional
elements there as far as the fires go
raza manas says please come to norway
and eat it
stat holden statholdgarden which has a
michelin star the norwegian with a star
for the longest time i would love to do
it
i've been to finland i've been to
denmark i've been to estonia
i have never been to norway but it is
high on my list
norway and then nars that's the trip
um big thank you to little blue doggy
for the six month subscription
as well as nick lovin nick lovin
has signed up very much appreciate that
mark fillion
says i do not know if those videos could
be explained by the fact that trump had
what seems like a band-aid on the right
hand yesterday
trump's had band-aids on his right hand
for a while and it is either from
i mean listen it's in all it's 99 from
an iv
and it could have been from when he was
at walter reed or he could have
continued receiving
any kind of transfusions um anything
from hydration to
uh rum reservoir as he calls it
um while at the white house so yeah
in all in all likelihood it's from an iv
of some kind we just don't know what
lawanda buchanan says i voted in person
yesterday it was not crowded i am in
texas
excellent early voting love it
lieutenant frank drebin from police
squad says please
search spitting image trump on youtube
very funny
i'll do that later it's always a risk to
do youtube searches
on stream chakaseki
whoa we lost chakuseki chakaseki says
perhaps trumpel stiltskin could purchase
his much desired suburban female vote
for a hundred and thirty thousand ahead
his usual fee for buying it fealty from
women
that could be an idea mori
says grand master ben feingold if you're
in here i
love you love you too david okay so
that's a message we are going trans
platform um message from youtube
to benjamin feingold on twitch
very exciting very exciting
parker peter says is it just me or does
trump sound worse each time he rallies
yes
he does you're it's not just you claire
houlihan
says voted today in texas saw you a
while back on the serfs can i get
another boomer-esque trans rights that
was hilarious
maybe later maybe later i don't want to
get memed into oblivion
uh thanks to benjamin noah for the
twitch
prime subscription very much appreciate
that
um grace voted absentee
in montana yesterday blue ticket all the
way down i work in healthcare covert
exploding here
thank you for keeping me saying yeah we
i did a story two days ago or
yesterday i think wait what day is it
yesterday
yeah because we were off on monday for
uh the holiday
um of 13 states are at new
seven day highs seven day rolling
average highs for coronavirus
and montana is one of the worst three
one of the worst three
uh in the country right now mj says did
you know there's a billboard that is
against trump by the airport in des
moines
yeah jim acosta um tweeted it
let me see if i can find that
it's pretty funny so somebody bought a
billboard right by
the airport and what there it is here it
is
trump coveted super spreader event with
an arrow pointing towards the airport
very very clever
wonder how much it cost don't don't have
any idea
let's see hello i am a man from pakistan
looking for beautiful wife from you this
is
not the stream for that my friend this
is a different kind of stream
ant and sharon say hey david praying the
tangerine chosen one gets voted out
great job we love you pack
thank you i appreciate that rot kreutz
says i'm tired of seeing both sides or
bad from my friends on facebook this
isn't a both side's election covet is in
the line
yeah both sides stuff it's uh it's it's
vile
it's vile quite frankly at this point um
danny thompson says i have to laugh
there's almost nothing that screams
millennial
more than having worked at circuit city
yeah
kalyn says did you and kyle interact
when the gnome chomsky twitter madness
was going on
no i haven't heard from kyle for a while
i don't know what he's been up to
um so that uh yeah
james montalbano says this october 14th
i'd like to wish you a happy hero's day
in remembrance of all the souls we lost
during the sudden departure
i have no idea what that is i hope i'm
not being disrespectful that i don't
know what that is
um martin maldonado says i meant to
super chat this but
ronald trump is going to be late just do
his picture in picture
and focus on biden's town hall no i
think that trump will be on time for a
televised town hall badger says hello
from the uk hope you fix the trump
disaster
i hope so too so i can get back to the
uk skunk
games says will you do a segment about
the harebrained hunter bite in new york
post article soon you know it's so
ridiculous i don't even know that i want
to do a segment on it
but i have it in my maybe pile for
tomorrow
aaron's uh oh i'm sorry not aaron anand
is asking
uh whoa major zoom there anon is asking
which network i would be affiliated with
if i had a pick
i don't want to be affiliated with any
of them to be perfectly frank
actually as trump lands i have i have
launched a new spanish language show
this we did a soft launch so i didn't
mention it but there is a network a
spanish language network in the u.s now
i'm going to say it so
if you're not from argentina you would
pronounce it estrella
if you are from argentina like i am we
would say estricha
and the program is sundays at 4 00 p.m
east 1 p.m pacific half hour a day show
in spanish and we are in episode
3 i don't know if it will go beyond the
election for now they are sort of
pre-election specials
but you can find that at 4 pm that's
e-s-t-r-e-l-l-a
okay which means star in spanish
it is spanish language for
spanish-speaking viewers in the united
states related to american
politics very exciting we are two
episodes in as soon as i have
clips made available to me i will be
posting them uh
on the internet the trump masks
and shirts i guess are starting to to uh
to be tossed around
oh and by the way on the spanish show we
have some very exciting guests scheduled
i don't even want
to announce them because things are so
crazy they could get cancelled and then
i
sort of like you know i i there's no
point in that
but we have some really great guests
scheduled for the
spanish show coming up very very soon
uh okay ophelia wants to know if i ever
eat leftovers out of the trash
i bet you do i don't i don't do that
um i think that there was once
i mean listen i don't know that this is
too controversial but once there was a
misunderstanding between my girlfriend
and i
and a box a packaged item
ended up in the trash it was a sealed
item and at that point there was really
only like plastic wrapping in the trash
i did pull out the package it was a
closed package and i said that's good
that's good uh that's not trash let's
take that out of there
okay is that story even real even i
don't know
even i don't know all right thank you
keegan says not sure if you've talked
about it but have you reached out to tim
poole about debating lefties
no i have not reached out to tim about
that would love to see you
one with him again yeah maybe maybe
colby says i'm in the des moines area
this event is an embarrassment well said
very much appreciate that uh
do i still have a goal of 1500 twitch
subs by the end of the month
yeah i mean listen we we're at 1 237
twitch subs right now
the most where we peaked was i think
about 14
20 at the end of september now we're
back down i would love to be at 1500 by
the end of october
i think it's doable i think you know we
were about a thousand
at the start of the month so we were
roughly halfway it could certainly
happen
it's certainly something that could
happen but what i do want to mention
and i have limited these these hard
sells to only
one per uh stream i really do want to
make a very
humble i throw myself at your mercy a
very humble plea
that you consider supporting all of the
work that we do by grabbing a membership
on my website
okay joinpakman.com you get an extra
show every day just for you where i'm
joined by our producer great producer
patrick ford
we uh primarily depend on that as a
source of revenue
it's the largest single source of
revenue we have on an ongoing basis
and every time you sign up this blue bar
starts filling up and if enough people
sign up it explodes off the side
side of the screen the coupon code above
my head
2020 now saves 66
so we're talking about teeny tiny
amounts of money
if you're down to your last dollar don't
sign up i'm telling you right now
don't you dare sign up if you're down to
your last dollar a couple bucks
if a dollar 80 a month seems reasonable
to you
okay and you think what we do is worth
it
grab a membership use the coupon code
2020 now uh you can pay monthly for two
bucks a month
or pay for the entire year and it's a
dollar eighty-eight
and i will thank everybody okay
everybody will get thank yous
and we did a few weeks ago have a
website crash
because so many people people were we
were about to run out of memberships and
people were beating down the door
and each other to get memberships the
website crashed
you understand it went dead and we've
since quadrupled
the resources on our website it is now
more than equipped to handle anything
you can throw at it at it other than the
ddos attack that took us down about six
weeks ago during a stream
but other than that um the website is
very well equipped and i have uh very
very strong faith
that we are going to do it we are
getting ready for donald trump here in
des moines iowa
we still have a lot of super chats
coming in
harper is asking how to send pictures
through my website contact form
upload to imager send imager link
upload to imager send imager link
rocco's modern life asks on twitch any
chance lindsey graham
loses yeah yeah there's a chance i mean
if
if you say david bet money even odds i
think lindsey graham wins
but i don't think he wins by that much
and i could be wrong and i would love it
i would love it uh oh this is bad news
chaka seki says
i use the illegal coupon code 2020 now
and immediately had my apartment raided
by ice who performed
serial cavity searches on me still worth
it says chakaseki to have a membership
yeah the other day someone wrote me and
said right after getting a membership
using
this huge discount they were pulled over
and they were like this is it
that discount being so big is going to
screw me
turns out they only had a tail light out
so no uh
no big deal all right thanks to jennifer
hall by the way who's new member number
five
and uh matthew august is new member
number six at join pacman.com a
delightful
number the goal is 25 it's modest i
think
quakes says on twitch thank you for the
content david deepak pakman ii
love it love it it does look like it
could rain so we are going to see donald
trump maybe with a bad voice
and possibly in the rain i'm guessing
that it will be a short
rally if that is the case
other super chats i don't want to miss
uh
let's see ryan says thoughts on kyle
kolinsky response to chomsky interview
didn't see it i don't watch any uh shows
that are like mine
i only watch this i only do my show
so i never know what anybody is saying i
have i have no idea what kyle said
steven robbins also known as ronald
reagan that says d-man it's raygun
would you sit in a studio to debate tim
poole or are you two afraid like beta
sam cedar
listen i i'm not flying to be in a uh
studio with tim pool during coronavirus
uh that is not high on my list of
priorities i want to be here and i want
to be healthy
so i can keep doing the show and
streaming and
all of those things the idea of being in
an enclosed room with tim pool during a
pandemic is not
my idea of fun yabbit says now that
little rocket man has revealed his big
big rocket is the honeymoon over
let's hope so sean reid
says he is not the president every time
i hear president trump my knee-jerk
reaction
is to add air quotes a phoenix
says deepak i think orange mango face
will be flying high at rally
taking his cronies on his first mission
to nars i think trump may be high as a
kite
because he needed to take probably a
steroid to get rid of that horrible
voice he had earlier
i don't know if you heard this earlier
but listen to this this is just really
really bad
instead of corrupting horrendous trade
deals written by lobbyists and special
interests
again some of you i negotiated
pro-american trade deals
based on the principles of fairness and
reciprocity
very important i ended the
nafta nightmare and signed the brand new
u.s mexico so my guess is that he would
have taken a little hit of something
uh legal certainly on the way to this um
to this to this speech so uh i think he
will be flying high yes that's that's
the long and short of it
dustin says hey i listen every day on
spotify
just found out my mom will not vote for
trump again in michigan enjoy the rally
from hell well good for your mom
good for your mom very very important
all right we have people signing up like
people have never done before okay
sam perman is new member number seven
fahem islam is new member number eight
sarah payne is new member number nine
austin hemingway gross
is number 10. lane doby
is number 11. sean dalton is number 12
and lauren islas is number 13
very much appreciate it uh we have a
very big membership drive going right
now
we may run out of memberships today if
uh
if that's any indication we are standing
by for donald trump let's see if they've
got the music pumping
they do okay we'll keep that muted until
uh time the time comes
matt says hashtag heroes day the sudden
departure
kevin says hey again david even if biden
wins what advice
do you have for people like me who are
feeling hopeless with how divided the
u.s
is current state let's first see what
happens in the election then we'll talk
about divisive politics okay
one thing at a time bruce asks whether
there will be monster trucks after the
rally
i don't know if that's big in iowa but
maybe
alan says on its stream i am from
scotland
my band debbie klein have a song about
the last four years
let's get high while we still got time
watch your show all the time
keep on keeping on all right thank you
alan oliver says david i watched the
confirmation hearing today and i'm truly
enraged and disgusted
please give any advice you have on
keeping calm do not watch the
confirmation hearings would be my advice
sadly um some aggressive comments about
tim poole i don't know that i need to be
reading those
loidy says i used to live in des moines
considering the people i met over 20
years ago doesn't surprise me
chaka seki oh okay we read that one
already
joao says hey david greetings from
brazil do you think the new york post
story regarding hunter will have any
impact on the polls
i do not i do not i challenge you
to disagree with me alt wrong anon
has subscribed on twitch and says hi
david love the show
check out this video i turned your
second jessie lee peterson interview
into a bet
between two ferns episode the the links
are are um
are a censor they're not said they're
you know blocked on twitch
please email me that right now on my
website contact form i would love to
watch that on stream
uh a between two ferns episode with me
and jesse
i would love to see that email it to me
right now
i'll get it while trump is talking and
then
we can uh maybe review that after the
fact that would be really really great
would be fantastic actually uh
all right what else do we have going on
here
a lot of excitement as we await donald
trump in des moines iowa
we've looked at some memes we've read
some super chats
we are now i know everybody is just
bursting with excitement to hear what
donald trump might say today
but it you will have to wait just a
little bit longer
thanks to amanda anderson for grabbing a
soyboy level membership on youtube
cooper mccartney says i predict a
comeback reality tv show from trump when
he loses
peggy says i love listening to you make
my day thanks peggy appreciate it
lunkish says okay no i'm not i'm not
auctioning off
underwear guys i'm sorry ours says thank
you to the mods for deleting the
trumpets no remember mods have been
directed not to ban or censor trumpists
in the chat
we censor you know hate speech n-word
anti-semitism
unproductive trolling and and that type
of thing but you people are allowed to
be trumpists in the chat that's no
problem whatsoever
none whatsoever how is the fight for 1.1
going yeah i know it doesn't sound as
exciting
so we had this big um sort of like push
for a million subscribers as we get
ready to see trump and we got to a
million now we're pushing for 1.1 and
we're almost halfway there we're at 1.04
million
on youtube almost 1.05 i know that the
numbers are not
as exciting to say let's get to 1.1
million
but i would love it if you help me
continue to build the youtube channel so
if you are watching on youtube and
you're not subscribed uh please hit
subscribe
and um we are very very strongly
focused on growing twitch as well and we
are actually just 13 followers short of
54
000 just 13. so uh we we do want to keep
growing twitch i think 2021
we were we were having a very uh big um
sort of uh what would we call it a
meeting of the minds
in a sense about 2021 i think 2021
could be a really big year on twitch for
us
as we continue to expand on various
platforms and by the way i'm not joking
i think 2021 could be a big year on tick
tock for us a lot of people don't know
that
we actually without i've never we've
never really done anything on tick tock
other than post little clips
and we have 16 000 followers on tick
tock i think it's an interesting
platform we're reaching a completely
different audience
and uh why not right we'll reach people
wherever they want to be reached
kim says i live eight miles from his
rally in pennsylvania last night
i could hear his cultists cheering and
screaming that is ugly
that is ugly thanks to insurance nerds
and andy
as well as rose for grabbing youtube
memberships
dee campbell says hey david where is the
spanish content so right now i am doing
a half hour a week spanish program
on the network estrella or as we say in
argentina
estresia all right it's sunday
4p east 1p west
only in the 46 cities
that have the channel okay so sadly
you must check your local listings as
the kids say
uh all right let's see i have this
between
two ferns thing that was sent to me
let me just preview it a tiny bit
um
oh this is but this is old isn't it i
thought that i had already
reviewed this on stream uh
oh no i haven't oh okay okay okay okay
that's interesting
let's um let's just look at a tiny bit
of it
just like a split second see what this
is up
[Music]
oh my god it's already good we are
amazing welcome to to the uh fall estate
youtube live
i'm jesse lee peterson apologize for the
late start but we are black
and black people are late we start on cp
time
oh my god that's and i have with me
david pacman
he is the progressive host of the
political
television radio program the david
patman show
david thank you for coming i i can't
believe i'm here i know it's amazing
last time we didn't end well i remember
right
do you remember i remember i i had to
kick you off my show you kicked me off
you said i never have that idiot back on
my show
you called me a girly man yeah what
changed your mind about having me back
after the ban
that's really my producer just because i
fight with you
doesn't mean i don't love you okay yeah
you love me
i don't really know you yeah well i love
you thank you are you surprised
not really were you surprised that i
threw you off the radio show
not really oh you were not answering
that's what it was
all right very cool so i would like to
look at that in more detail at a very
very uh so
a very very uh close point in time to
where we are right now
um but that's great stuff that's great
stuff thanks to dev tv
9 fredicini and djwrx for the twitch
prime subs
i really do appreciate that um
other super chats coming in mark says do
we think that the new york times
bombshell hunter biden report
is all they have as their october
surprise if so sad weak low energy
i don't know if that's the october
surprise if it is it's very very weak
very very weak uh corey edward
tanya have all grabbed youtube subs
david lindsey
rob says do you have a better coupon
code for trump so he can afford a
membership you know 2020 now is
basically as good as it gets
oh let me thank a few people though so i
don't fall behind
anna contreras is new member number 14.
brad bazemore is number 15.
stephen flanagan is new member number
16. keith anderson
is number 17 let's see if i can keep up
with that blue bar
a big thank you to steve mckinney who's
new member number 18
today anon annonson
is new member number 19. michael lent
nelson
is number 20. matt bowen is number 21
matt quinney a lot of mats is number 22.
lynn winters is new member number 23 at
joinpackman.com
love it i will keep up with the bar
throughout the entire event so don't
don't worry about that
uh other super chats here
oh if you're yeah let me repeat because
a lot of people are just joining us
by the way thank you to the
um to everybody watching on all
platforms right now the plan for
tomorrow night there are competing town
halls tomorrow night with joe biden
and donald trump biden's is going two
hours eight to ten eastern
whereas trump's is only one hour eight
to nine i wonder why trump is only doing
an hour it is interesting
um i my plan is to stream
both of them and the way i think i will
do it is we'll do an hour of trump and
an hour of biden
eight to nine east will do trump and
nine to ten east we will do biden
and it will be on youtube i don't know
about other platforms uh there are
reasons why
i i believe it will be safe to stream on
youtube whereas it may not be on other
platforms
so if you don't see me anywhere else
find me on youtube
essentially 24 hours to the minute i
will start at 7 30 p.m eastern time
tomorrow night
and i think it'll be a really great uh i
think it'll be a really really
beautiful evening okay a magical evening
i would even say
steven says signed up on your website i
used your illegal coupon
code which trump which turned trump into
biden
and biden into trump who wins now we
just won't know thanks obama
all right very confusing message but i
appreciate the support
b smith says go check out bo of the
fifth column okay
barbara has grabbed a sub insurance
nerds says
gracias por todo lo que so
thank you thanks for all you do brother
chakuseki says i just lost chakuseki
where did that go what do you think
trump's cocktail is today
i predict dextroamphetamine
dexamethazone
bluetrue and regeneron
in a mushroom coffee slurry trump
strikes me as a slurry guy
for sure and there's a couple different
meanings for for that
br says will there be a youtube channel
for the spanish show don't know i've
actually
just been hired to to host the show
and i don't know exactly what the full
distribution is going to be
so i don't want to speak out of turn on
that nathan
asks whether i saw the georgia special
election polls a democrat seems to have
taken the lead
let's hold our breaths i did see the
polls
stephen wants people to vote so the
nightmare can end
lux elliott says i imagine the local
walmart is empty right now
well said how crazy is it that i haven't
been to a walmart in 20 years
is that insane um
and i haven't been to a fast food
restaurant in just as long with the
exception of the kfc incident which
i'm not going to go into right now
that's not i don't want to do that
right now david van horn is new member
number 24.
baseem bashir is new member number 25
and peter o'malley is new member number
26
you all know what happens when we get to
25
i like to say let's go for 50. and let's
absolutely do it right now
jethro asks what trump is doing on the
plane right now
prayers drugs mobile tanning salon i
really don't know
yeah these delays are bizarre lots of
jello says honestly david you look good
in orange
it's like a cute social democrat pumpkin
wow i don't know if that's good or bad
kaden says david did you coordinate
response regarding tim poole with sam
you two had the same answer two betas
for sure
i didn't respond i wasn't even involved
in it i don't know what you're talking
about
i haven't responded anything to anybody
um kjv says any chance you open the
phones this afternoon please
probably not because i've got to make uh
i i've got a
tortellini soup i'm making tonight and
um
trump is is already very very late so
very unlikely
maybe tomorrow maybe tomorrow since when
when there are televised events they
they tend to run on time more frequently
thanks to shoulder x for subscribing on
twitch as well as
shelbs tx len one ntc
egad deep doob
some of these are tough to pronounce
over on twitch but i'm doing the best i
can
um okay
de mighty booze says not sure what that
guy is talking about
i live in des moines and its county is
very is blue
every election there is trump most there
there are probably from rural areas i'm
having a little trouble parsing the
grammar but i think i get the idea
matthew long says what's your position
on third party voting i'm in favor of
third parties
we need to do away with first past the
post to really get third parties to be
viable
right now the risk is too great when you
vote third party that you end up helping
the candidate you most
dislike in what we know of as the
spoiler
effect and we certainly don't want that
thanks to austin anderson who's new
member number 27
and lee a life is new member number 28
as we get ready to hear from captain
covid
the mango menace the tangerine terror
mauve mussolini maybe i'm not really so
sure about that
but there he is carrying covet masks it
looks like once again let's take a quick
listen
okay yeah i can't do that so i'll keep
uh seeing what you guys are up to
david abel says this five dollars is for
that between
two ferns parody thank you oh my god
they don't have nearly enough flags you
can still see trump's legs through them
austin says when's that orange garbage
bag full of mango pulp
gonna come rolling down the stairs right
now
right now owen says hi david from
ireland looking forward to the day when
america gets back to normality and i can
visit again
when the looney isn't the president take
care
thank you thank you very much
dino sax says hey david donato from the
uk here did you see the australian
interview with sarah huckabee sanders
worth the watch
i did it is well done very very much
well done
excellent excellent interview patrice
mortimore says what did patrice say
i think trump must be hawking up a
hairball in the plane
trump is looking the he's looking
labored already
i don't know if you guys can tell he
does not look good here and he was
really struggling earlier today to speak
during an interview
let's see what other stream elements we
have
uh we have this one and then uh we have
this one
okay i think we'll stick here for the
time being
[Applause]
see what we got
beautiful spray tan
he actually does seem lower energy right
now
this should be interesting
[Applause]
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you everybody
[Applause]
thank you very much everybody hello des
moines it's been a good time the voice
is bad
it's a little better than earlier but
it's pretty bad
yeah i even brought a hat they said sir
it is so windy out there
sir routine already i said well my hair
is very powerful it's very strong
i can't handle it but i voted just in
case it may get pretty bad but it's
pretty windy
so thank you all very much and i'm
thrilled to be back
a little more of all the american
heartland with thousands of loyal
hard-working iowa patriots
and 20 days from now we're going to win
this state we're going to win
four more years in the white house we're
going to keep it going
and i must tell you you know i've just
uh
looked the poll just came out we're up
six okay big deal
where didn't we win by 11 or something
we're upset
in iowa and if i'm up six nobody has
ever done for iowa
and the farm belt and the farmers and
all
no more estate taxes no more anything i
saved ethanol
ethanol is said for me to only be up six
i'm a little bit concerned i'll tell you
that
i would be too because nobody's gonna do
for iowa what i did for iowa we've just
learned
through explosive documents published by
a very fine newspaper the new york post
that joe biden has been blatantly lying
about his involvement in his son's
corrupt
business so he's going to try to make it
a big deal
and this is a big smoking gun the newly
uncovered emails
reveal that a top executive from the
highly questionable ukrainian
company it's an energy company which
paid hunter
at least fifty thousand dollars a month
but it's now looking like it could be
a hundred and eighty three thousand
dollars a month that's a lot of money
would anybody in this audience take it
i'll take it we'll take it
despite the fact that he had absolutely
no experience
do nothing about energy wrote to hunter
arranging for a meeting to meet with
vice president joe biden
i've been saying this for a long time
with that family the same ukrainian
energy executive
even sent hunter an email saying quote
we urgently need your advice
on how you could use your influence
in other words hunter was being paid for
access to his vice president father
sort of like trump sold access to
himself through his inauguration slush
fund wow
russia
how about the russia hoax it turned out
that they were the ones that did the
russia
it was them no collusion
no collusion collusion these emails show
that biden's
repeated claim that he has never spoken
to hunter about his business dealings
were a complete lie it was a total lie
it's not totally clear it could be a lot
over and over because he's trying to
cover up a massive
pay-for-play scandal at the heart of it
what's crazy to me about this is
everything they're accusing biden of
doing trump has done definitively does
that not i mean like is there no
backfire risk because his followers
don't know or don't care
biden administration there was never
never
[Music]
[Applause]
just weeks ago joe stood before the
american people in a presidential debate
and told you that these claims had been
totally discredited
and that his son did nothing wrong but
now that turns out
to be a total lie now we can see clearly
that biden is a corrupt politician who
shouldn't even be allowed
to run for the presidency i see a lot of
people in chat saying this is going to
get cut short
you think it'll get cut short because of
trump's voice because it seems to be
improving
lame stream media right back there all
those cameras right back there
they're corrupt and they refuse to write
the story
there wasn't one time in almost four
years during my presidency
during the greatest political scandal in
u.s history
a witch hunt a horrible horrible
disgusting witch-hunt that should never
ever happen
to another presidency again and people
should pay for the crimes they committed
okay which turned out to be a total
illegal hoax
that false and libelous stories every
day
false and libelous stories and they knew
they were false too
they knew they were false they were
never taken down by twitter or facebook
or the mainstream media never once yet
with biden today
they take negative posts down almost
before they even go up
they're trying to protect him they're
trying to protect biden
they take him down and i was just
getting off that magnificent plane
behind us air force one
imagine clapping for a plane and i mean
okay it's like if airbus is unveiling a
new plane you clap but this is just the
president they say
kaylee mcany you know kaylee mcnair
daley mcinerney
she's uh incredible they closed down her
account
she's the white house press secretary
because she's reporting the truth
they closed down her account so not
[Applause]
wrote all this available and then he
goes and he works at the department of
justice and he took it
didn't he bring it to the fbi the wife
writes it she gets paid a lot of money
resort is finally out of the department
of justice
a couple of years too late that's all
he should be not only in the department
of justice outbox he should be someplace
else okay
eight months after his alleged meeting
with
the burmese uh executives so this uh
what did he just say bibariza i think
was he trying to say burisma did anybody
catch that
bibariza is that like a justin bieber
thing president joe biden went to
ukraine
and threatened to withhold one billion
dollars in aid
if they did not fire the prosecutor that
was investigating his son
and the company that his son worked for
that's
very miserable documents
sounds like he's saying propecia almost
one of joe's trips to ukraine
hunter emailed his business partner
saying his lucrative contract
should begin now think of that this is
really bad now
right now it's got to begin it's go the
whole thing is so incredible
here's a guy look let's just put it in
simple language
he got thrown out of the military
switched a simple language good idea
he didn't have a job for a long time his
father becomes vice president
and he's making millions and millions
and millions of dollars a year
think of it no think of it
think of it it's like uh it's hungry
stuff the crooked hillary
and it's the crooked joe
you know when a democrat voter here in
iowa
asked joe last year you remember if his
son raked in money in exchange
for providing access joe called that man
a damn liar you're a damn liar
sort of like all trump's kids kid's
making millions of dollars
he had nothing he didn't have a job
thrown out of the military sadly but
thrown out of the military
and he knew nothing about energy he knew
nothing about investments
knew nothing about china how about he
walked away a billion and a half dollars
to manage for china
they don't do that with the most
brilliant people on wall street
vice president biden you owe the people
of america an apology because it turns
out
you are a corrupt politician right
trump looking for water now i don't
think he's doing well guys
joe biden must immediately release all
emails
meetings phone calls transcripts and
records related
to his involvement and his family's
business dealings
influence paddlings around the world
paddlings including
china and including russia including
russia
they're paddling businesses
well joe biden was giving china all of
our jobs they can't
you know where they came from iowa and
plenty of other places but they came
from iowa
he was giving them they were taking our
jobs they were taking our factories
they were taking everything they were
taking our wealth
and i gave you 28 billion dollars say
thank you very much president xi
it came right out of china and because
of that everybody's happy in
iowa how did he pronounce the thing i
want to type it in i don't remember how
he pronounced it how did he say
nobody else would have done it nobody
else would have done it the biden family
treated
the vice presidency as a for-profit
corporation flying around the globe
collecting millions of dollars from
china and ukraine and russia and other
countries
in fact the wife of the mayor of moscow
gave hunter biden a check for three
people the wife of the mayor
m-a-r-e that's a female horse his father
gave away the store
to russia including crimea remember
crimea
the bidens got rich while america got
robbed
by contrast and this is so true and
so easily true and i'm so proud of it in
so many ways
i've given up billions of dollars to
serve as your president
and it's my greatest honor of a lifetime
[Applause]
[Music]
the only way that's true is that he
ruined his image trump trump really
seems to be
struggling here is he looking for water
he
i think trump's really having a problem
you guys see what's happening i think
i ran for president because i could not
sit back any longer and watch
the terrible injustices being done
to the american people and it's true
and by the way before the china play
came in we had the greatest economy in
the history of the world
and now it's going right back there our
stock market is very close
to a number that was even higher does
everybody have your
401k ready because it's going through
the room
the whole crowd is going to have the
best year we've ever had
and we're going to have tax cuts not tax
increases they want to increase your
taxes
they want to increase your taxes so they
can spend it on the green new deal
it's another beauty i cannot sit
idly by and watch career politicians
like joe biden
continue bleeding this country dry and
that's what it is
you know you can say whatever you want
you can say whatever you want
but when you have a kid that follows we
gotta watch it by the way take a look at
his brother
his brother all of a sudden is building
a big housing development in iraq
have you ever built a development before
no i haven't
take a look at the whole family it's a
corrupt family joe biden
personifies the selfless gotta get some
paper towels guys who got rich and
powerful at your expense
take a look at the people that are
funding his campaign people assumed that
they'd be funding my campaign
i don't want them we don't want them we
never needed them
we don't want them but they betrayed
american workers disparage american
values
and crushed our middle class
for decades biden and his cronies
laughed while they shipped
millions of your jobs to their friends
in foreign countries in countries that
you've never even heard of
they live behind gated walls and they
flooded your communities with illegal
immigration
deadly drugs ms-13 savages
that assault rape and murder innocent
americans
they forced our fellow citizens to live
in crumbling inner cities
while they spent trillions of dollars on
never
ending foreign wars they just never
ended but you know we're bringing all
our soldiers back home you know that
we've been doing it for a long time
and it's not easy not easy the
military-industrial complex not the
easiest thing but we're bringing him
back home we're almost finished in
afghanistan coming in
we're dealing we're down to a small
number
coming home by the end of the year
hopefully the end of the year shortly
thereafter
in syria we're out totally out and by
the way we crushed
before i did this we crushed 100
of the isis caliphate
100
we crushed a hundred percent we have the
greatest military in the world and by
the way we have built
we have still um
so i just tell you from iowa you know
you're a very powerful state politically
you're uh a big state to me being in
your heart
but you have a tremendous influence and
a tremendous power
and you've never let me down you just
came in
and we won by so much you know they say
if a republican wins by one point i
think i won by
11 right 11.
that was early in the night remember
that
they said donald trump has won the state
of iowa
then they said man he won by 11 points
what's going on that was just the
beginning
then we won ohio we won ohio by eight
points they said what's going on you
know it's one thing you want to say but
when you went by a lot
and that was the beginning of something
and i'll tell you what we have
more enthusiasm now than we ever did
four years ago
there really is true
and we have great poll numbers although
you know you see a lot of the fake poll
numbers they're doing
they'll do anything they can they're
called suppression polls
yeah there they go look look at the red
lights they start to go off as i start
to point
obviously they want the ratings in
another way they don't want to have the
ratings and you're telling
cnn that they're a fraud and they're
broadcasting
no that was one of the greatest that was
one of the greatest evenings ever
there were those that say it was the
most exciting evening in the history of
television highest rated evening in the
history of television
okay we're back and you know what the
election we have
coming up on november 3rd is actually
more important it's actually more
important
in 2016 you voted to fire the failed and
decrepit political class and you elected
an outsider as your president
and i finally put america first it's
called make america great again
is he still looking for water what's
going on
oh he wants the hat it's windy out here
okay that's so he's worried about it you
can wear the hat i can wear the hat
unbelievable
oh my god it's a cult yeah
should i take off the tie or not what do
you think
i don't know maybe yes
this is crazy
elect this man can you imagine
oh that feels so much better
that feels better that feels good now we
can all just relax and have a good time
no but it's uh it's great to be with you
seriously we've had a great
history here together what we've done
for you
and what we've done for the farmers and
what we've done for everything
you know two weeks ago you had the
largest order of corn
in the history of our country right corn
two weeks ago
you're the largest order of soybeans in
the history of our country
and the largest order of beef but you
know why because
china wants to keep me happy that's why
it was from china wait so china is
behaving or china's not behaving never
have been allowed they could have
stopped it
they didn't stop it they should have
stopped it the only reason i'm your
president
is because the previous administration
did a poor job
so poor in fact that i said i'm going to
run for president
and you know what if they did a good job
i wouldn't have run
and if they did a good job i guess i
wouldn't have won
when you think i wouldn't have run and i
wouldn't have won
but they were so bad and it turns out
they were so totally corrupt
we did not come this far to overcome
this much and fight this hard
only to surrender our country back to
the depraved
washington swamp
you know when i would say drain the
swamp
i used to say it you know drained the
swamp and people liked it i hated the
expression
i hated it well he didn't do it either
this is a hokey expression
and i put it in one speech the place
went crazy i said i'm starting to like
that expression
that's interesting you guys think
pulling the tie off was a ruse because
trump's having trouble breathing is that
that's interesting that's an interesting
idea i like it
but you know what when i say drain the
swamp i had no idea the swamp was that
dirty that disgusting and that deep
it's true if i don't sound like a
typical washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician thank
god
and i don't want to insult our great
politicians because you have some great
ones with us tonight
but if i don't always play by the rules
of washington and washington
establishment it's because
i was elected to fight for you harder
than
ever and i'll tell you what i fight for
you
any president has ever fought for anyone
it's not easy but i love it because
we're making tremendous progress
we're making tremendous progress and the
fact is that no
administration in their first three and
a half years
has ever done as much as
this administration has done you take a
look at those
okay and you know it's amazing because
they always challenge you they challenge
you and everything
they never even challenged me on that
statement i make that statement all the
time they just stand and they say
it's just too meaningless to even
discuss he's right we did more than
anyone else they say he's right
right now i'm fighting to eradicate the
virus rebuild the economy and save our
country from the radical left
and that's exactly what we're doing
as a candidate joe biden has made yet
another corrupt bargain in exchange for
his party's nomination
he has handed control to the socialists
and marxists
and lunatic left-wing fringe
that are really running that party he's
not running it let's face it
joe is shot okay whether you like it or
not we can all be nice
it's gonna be my turn someday it's even
gonna be your turn someday
my friends someday but you know when it
is your turn you can't be president
i would love for trump to name a marxist
he's 100
putin of russia 100 kim jong-un by the
way whatever happened to that war we
were supposed to be
trump keeps saying that someone talked
trump out of that trump was looking at
that and someone talked trump out of it
joe has lost it in his best day he
wasn't a smart man
everybody knows that but joe is gone
if he wins the radical left we'll be
running the country
they're addicted to power and god help
us if they get it
we'll never be the same country and we
will never be able to recover
and we are on a basis and i'll tell you
something the country was coming
together
i was telling a very very actually a
very good reporter today
that our country was coming together
because we were having such success that
i was being called
by people that normally i wouldn't be
speaking to
too much they don't want me i don't want
them but we had the best employment
numbers in history
african american hispanic american
numbers women
asian everything high school diploma
our high school diploma colleges phds
we had the best numbers in every
category 160 million jobs we were never
even close to that
we were at 160 million jobs and it was
all coming together
people let's get together let's talk you
know it's like the guy who's never for a
single day had an approval of 50
says that the country was more united
than ever during his reign
and now it's back to the drawing boards
but we're going to have a strong v the
quarter the third quarter is going to be
incredible when you see the numbers
not that i know anything because i don't
want to give you inside information
because i don't have it
they'll say he's giving away inside
information they are sick
but why do you see the third quarter
numbers and it's going to be right
before it's going to be right before the
election before the november 3rd
although a lot of people
will have voted by that time get out and
vote you got to get out and vote got to
get out and vote but we're
we were really coming together because
that's you know look ultimately we want
to come together everybody come together
and we were really coming together and
then we got hit crazy
horrible situation could have been
stopped china stopped it from
going into the rest of china but they
didn't stop it
from coming out and going to europe and
the united states and the rest of the
world 188 countries
so we're now putting it together we had
it
done and now we're doing it again and
next year
will be even stronger than last year
last year was the best year we've ever
had
and this coming year will be even better
than last year
okay unless somebody comes along and
says let's quadruple your taxes which is
what
i've noticed that yeah more and more
people so this woman's gone mask off
this woman's gone mask off this guy's
got it pulled down this kid
there's a woman oh there's this woman
she pulled her mask off this guy's got
it around his chin so any if
if something were to come out of his
chin out of his uh throat
it would be okay no uh no nose covering
here this guy's got no
you know it's everybody's been slowly
pulling them off they actually mean it
you know they actually mean it so we're
going to uh
get it going to a level that nobody can
ever turn course on us nobody can ever
change you know
i tell the story for years as a student
of
economies i just love it i love watching
it i love doing it
he loves it i love seeing the results
because the results have been so
incredible
but as a student i used to hear for
years for 10 years
2019 china because look let's face it
china's
1.4 billion people we're 325
uh not including illegal immigrants that
are in the country
frankly and we don't even know what that
number is how many do we have we have no
idea sir well i have an idea
by the way our southern border is now
stronger
than it's ever been
but we have 325 300 i just want to
remind everybody
trump saying this stuff this garbage
it's bad
the fact that crowds cheer for it is
really really really bad about what it
says for america
he's a very smart looking guy you're
loaded with money i bet look that's why
he's in the front row
he's in the front row and he didn't have
to stand here for three days to get
there i can tell he's got it
but right 2019 that china was going to
overtake as well
you go back six months seven months not
only weren't they overtaking we were
beating them by leaps and bounds
and getting bigger and bigger and
growing and growing
and taxing them and taxing them and
taking in billions and billions of
tariffs
and when they targeted iowa and the
farmer does trump realize he can't
really tax china like does he still not
get that it's
domestic companies paying the tariffs
five percent tariff on everything
and i gave a lot of the money although i
don't want to say too loudly 28 billion
i gave you
16 and 12. i said to sonny perdue
secretary of agriculture great guy loves
he knows more about farms
i said sonny what's the number he said
two years ago sir 12 billion they hit us
for
and last year 16 billion i said that's
okay we're going to put a 25
tariff the farmers are going to get 12
billion and then they're going to get 16
billion
okay and we're going to give that money
to our farmers
and that got our farmers even
what is he talking about there can't be
a single farmer in the crowd that
understands what he's saying
some of the farmers were making more
money the way they were doing it then by
working their asses off sounds like
socialism they were very very happy
but no we took care of our farmers no
other president is going to do that no
other
that's why that's why china got away
with all of this stuff for years
and we had plenty of money left over
after the 28 billion dollars
it went into the u.s treasury but they
got away with it
because they're threatening a president
like obama
we're going to target your farmers we're
going to target the middle of our
country
and obama would say oh betty we better
not get involved i said differently
i said if you do it if you do it then
what we're going to do is we're going to
tariff your goods and we'll give a lot
of that money to the people that you're
targeting
and you know the thing all right guys
just very very real here
does trump know when he says that that
american companies pay the tariffs but
he just keeps saying it anyway or does
he genuinely not know that it's american
companies paying the tariffs
wisconsin was incredible they never came
to me and said sir you can't let this
happen
they're stopping ordering they're not
ordering from us they never said it it's
a mix of people
interesting some say he knows something
right at some point we have to put up a
stand
and i didn't hear one even from fake cnn
they'd put people on television
that said i know it's not good but the
president is right
the president is right you did the right
thing
because otherwise it puts me in a bad
negotiating position you can't really
negotiate you know it's tough
it's tough i never i'll never forget
that about
the farmers it's incredible the other
thing i won't forget
you don't mind if i go off script this
time this guy now has taken his hand
off with enough with crazy hunter biden
and making millions of dollars a day
he made it because oh this guy's now
gone massive intellect
no but but you know the other thing
where's hunter is hunter here tonight
hunter hunter congratulations on making
a lot of money last year
you know the other thing i remember in
the white house
we had 36 farmers come to see me i'll
never forget it and they were getting
hit really hard this was two and a half
years ago early
and they came in to see me almost all
farmers
and they said sir we're you know we're
hurting but
uh you're doing the right thing sir i
never forget this meeting
it's earlier pictures of it uh many from
iowa yes people
love the states but many from iowa oh
like a vacation because everyone's
always asking me for money i want money
here i want my countries want money our
so-called allies are always asking for
money
please defend us even though then they
rip us off on trade you know we defend
them and then they rip us off
and trade they're always asking for
money so the farmers are in
and i said to them you know what i'm
going to do i'm going to do a big thing
i'm going to get you a lot of money and
i'm going to do for tariffs and i'm
going to do this to
this very early on the strategy and i'm
going to subsidize you guys you're going
to be so happy
and i used a terrible word they said sir
may i speak yes you can what do you want
to say
we don't want subsidies soon all we want
is a level playing field we don't want
anything
oh my god
right that's true i never heard that
most people they don't care call it
subsidy call it give me
cash just give me money the farmer said
we and by the way i could see there was
like a chill in the room i mentioned
that word i said did i say something
wrong
the farmers are unbelievable they're the
heart of the station
they said we don't want subsidy i'll
never forget it sir
the crowd's starting to sort of tune out
like the applause lines
are less you know energy filled
and this seems to happen a lot lately
where the crowd just doesn't know what
he's talking about
because i don't hear that most people
they don't care you can call it anything
you want
you call subsidy you call it anything
you want
i just think you people are incredible
okay
that's it enough
enough of that enough of that
enough of that are going to make him cry
and he hasn't cried in 40 years that guy
one of the most important issues for
iowa
is the whole thing that happened with
ethanol they were killing ethanol
back on the joe biden's vowed to abolish
fossil fuels he
supports all of the outside you know
this crusade to eliminate gas-powered
cars
and his running mate sponsors uh i i'm
agreeing with some people in the chat
i'll probably just do like 10 more
minutes of it i think we're getting a
sense of the crowd and what trump is
going to say
and then we still are offering mercy
bans if people know that this is really
bad for them if you want a mercy ban
from the moderators you can request one
and then that way you won't you know
have to watch any future ones even
accidentally
uh mercy ban requests can be sent in the
chat the moderators will will address
those
he just left the biden harris platform
will demolish
iowa ethanol you know that wiping out
the entire industry and we fought hard
for it you know we went through the
whole thing where we had no demand
because of the pandemic
and we all fought hard to get keep it
going and keep the ethanol going and we
did the
12 months you know i did 12 months
remember it was 8 months i said why not
12 and they couldn't give me a very good
answer
but i made it year round and 15 right
up from the 10 15 percent and it's great
stuff and when the market comes back
which is coming
this person was the only one expensive
gasoline that's not so bad right that's
not so bad
because nobody ever thought they'd see
gasoline with the two in the front of it
unless
we may run out of mercy bans before we
run out of memberships the way things
are going
well we are having problem with energy i
called russia
and i call saudi arabia and they reduce
production by more than 10 million
barrels a day
and our entire energy was saved all over
the world frankly they're not doing it
for us
but they're doing it for let's say
everybody and we have an incredible
country and we saved our energy industry
our energy jobs
and we are energy independent and it's a
beautiful thing
[Applause]
i think what's happening is during every
applause line one more mass comes off
see now this woman's got the mask off
well you can use the pumps okay do you
understand that
you can use the pumps this is you don't
have to go out and spend
hundreds of millions of dollars on new
pumps because you know with the
additional ethanol
the additional power some people say oh
make them buy new pumps
no i don't want you to buy new pumps you
don't have to so for those people that
understood what i just said
you know what i'm talking about right
you know the truth is trump's toilet
flushing material is much funnier than
the pumps
in our constitution i nominated
judge amy coney barrett to the united
states supreme court
right
and i'll tell you you know i don't mind
running against sleepy joe but i
wouldn't want to run against her you
mask off up here now she has to promise
please promise me amy you'll never run
no she's been great she's so outsmarting
these people these people with bad
intention
you look at some of the questions that
are being asked it's so obvious these
are not
great chess players let's face it let's
face it they're not great but then
they're horrible just horrible nasty
yeah we might talk to a doctor
chakaseki's asking for a mercy ban
lobotomy combination i'm gonna see if i
can talk to one of the great doctors at
mass general
um or or maybe even beth israel and see
if that's something we could do
and that sold me you know i believe in
that kind of thing it's called
intelligence i believe in intelligence
but i just want to uh haven't spoken to
her in a few days i want to just say
that we made the right choice right with
amen
and speaking about making the right
choice you made the right choice a long
time ago with a man named senator
chuck grassley no no
oh no
and you made the right choice and you're
going to do it again i hope because
she's great
joanie ernst we've got to defeat her
we must be there right now in washington
fighting to
confirm our great new justice
our future justice of the united states
supreme court
uh joni has been fantastic and she's
been fighting for iowa
values for a long time she'll call me
sir can we do this you nobody called me
more on ethanol
than joni and chuck in fact i used to
duck their calls tell them i'm not in
just tell them i'm not here
i can't take it anymore joni but that's
what a good senator is they want to
keep your state going they want to keep
our country going they love
the country they love our state that
they represent sir joni ernst you got to
get her in
and chuck grassley we don't have to
worry about him he'll be around forever
he's great
uh monday mike lee who had coronavirus
was standing above chuck grassley uh
talking
uh chuck grassley's 87. right and he's
being nice
and he looked at comey remember you know
the corrupt fbi director
and he looks at comey he looks at comey
corrupt guy and he just said did you
leak
and comey choked yes i did he said in
the house
now let's see what happens to him what
but i'll never forget chuck grassley and
he didn't mean it to be
mean he's just sort of like got that
rough voice did you leak
uh uh uh what uh yes i gave it to my uh
college professor friend from columbia
yes
remember that ah we love chuck what a
piece of work he is
if democrats win they will pack the
supreme court with radical left judges
sadly they probably won't biden doesn't
seem at all interested in that
if they win your second amendment is
gone definitely untrue
they'll empower violent mobs and shield
deadly criminals and terrorists very
simple
joe biden refuses to even answer
questions unpacking the supreme court
how about this
they go up to him do you want to pack
the court i'm not going to answer that
question
you know why because they don't ask it
if he doesn't you know me it would be
like uh
wait hold on did they not ask him or did
he not answer it which one which one was
it again uh i'm not gonna answer that
because i don't want to say
oh okay good next question can you no
can you believe it
this is the essence of our country we
can't allow this to happen
and the other thing is they don't ask
the second i put up a list of 45
great brilliant conservative and our
case
justices that go by the constitution as
written
etc etc okay so
he's got to put up the name of justices
or judges whoever he'd pick
to become a justice why does he have to
do that not doing that they're not
asking that question they don't ask
did you see the nbc thing last week
where they had an nbc town hall
it was designed for a child okay
when i get in they asked me things that
nobody ever even
contemplated could be thought of this
guy they're asking him these questions
nobody can believe it in fact
nbc took a lot of heat they took a lot
of hate
biden's agenda would be a catastrophe
for
iowa seniors for years biden tried to
cut social security
and medicare do you remember that you do
know he wanted to cut
your social security and so let's just
because it
we don't need to hear everything let me
just isolate that to get tell you what
so
trump says biden wanted to cut social
security in medicare
okay there's video from 1993
which is now 27 almost 28 years ago
during which biden was asked would you
take social security off the table a
priori
and biden said no i wouldn't a priori
take it off the table
at no point does that mean joe biden
wants to cut it and it was 27 years ago
and obviously joe biden's not not
running on that right now so this
is how these lies develop when they
asked a question at the debate where the
democrats were up there you had all
these democrats they started off at 26.
and in fact i said there's no way they
picked kamala
because she treated him worse than
anybody else and
her poll numbers were dropping like a
rock right but they asked
who is going to give the crowd is silent
this guy looks like he needs to go to
the bathroom this guy looks like he may
be completely catatonic
there's people who seem to be sleeping
where every once in a while their heads
pop
up when they wake up it's wild hell
they're asking
but do you remember his position he was
like this
their hands are all up we're gonna give
all our money away forget about all you
people
that's a big crowd by the way look at
that
show show it please
turn those cameras please that's a
beautiful crowd
that's beautiful but remember joe so he
said all right guys so listen i
i can tell because the audience is
fading we we've lost about 15
of the viewers people seem to have a
sense of this town of this uh
this this rally so i'm going to cut it
here and not subject people to more of
it tomorrow night we will hopefully have
some policy i am going to be starting at
7 30 p.m eastern
we're going to have the trump town hall
and the biden town hall
certainly on youtube other platforms
question mark okay guys
so i think this is probably enough uh
for for this eve evening
uh i appreciate everybody joining me we
will not subject anybody or
myself to any more of this now seven
years he's got the itch because he's
like
now trump seems to be ridiculing some
kind of spasm i don't even know
that's it for tonight we'll see
everybody back here in
about 23 hours see you then
you